public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
jean-luc mélenchon candidat bien sûr à
l'élection présidentielle est l'invité
de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
michel et merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec la fp
avec les échos et radio classique alors
comme chaque semaine trois grandes
parties trois grandes questions pour
vous d'abord au nom du peuple point
d'interrogation mais le créneau est
désormais occupé également par nicolas
sarkozy qui n'a que ce mot à la bouche
alors jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique sera
le premier à vous interroger dans un
instant ensuite stéphanie le rouge de la
lfp vous demandera quel visage aurait
votre france
insoumise si vous l'emportez enfin votre
vote révolutionnaire ouvre-t-il en fait
la route à la droite voire à l'extrême
droite au chaos selon l'accusation du
ministre jean marie le guen qui était
notre invité ici même la semaine
dernière bien voulu répondre et et c'est
mickaël szames est ce qui nous détruit
en a pas mieux à faire qu'à répondre à
de telles sottises
avez vous répondrais oui d'accord mais
qu'elle aimait ce qui sera là pour la
troisième partie de l'émission aura
également d'autres questions pour vous
mais d'abord jean luc mélenchon qu'une
question d'actualité
bien sûr la crise entre la france et la
russie avec vladimir poutine qui a
décidé d'annuler finalement sa venue à
paris
est-ce que vous soutenez françois
hollande dans son bras de fer pour faire
avancer la paix dit il
non pas du tout il ne fait rien avancer
du tout c'est une je désapprouve
absolument ce qu'il est en train de
faire qui est totalement contraire aux
intérêts de la france
d'abord envoyé jean marc ayrault porter
une lettre d'invitation monsieur poutine
pour ensuite dire qu'on ne sait pas si
on va le recevoir pour terminer les
russes dans une attitude plutôt
raisonnable pour éviter des incidents
qui ensuite nous entraîner dans une
escalade de mes aventures diplomatique
qui ne sont pas bonnes pour le pays
disent que il reporte la visite
l'attitude de françois hollande est
absolument insupportable nous sommes
totalement alignée sur les états unis
d'amérique nous courons devant et c'est
une attitude qui n'est pas du tout
conforme aux intérêts de la france qui
n'a qu'un préalable je le répète faire
avancer la paix à l'être notamment mais
c'est pas cette manière là qu'on fait
avancer la paix en quoi est ce que le
fait de provoquer des incidents
diplomatiques de cette nature fait
avancer la paix veut provoquer une
discussion sérieuse exclusivement sur la
syrie tout ça n'est pas sérieux surtout
en menaçant monsieur poutine de
l'envoyer au tribunal pénal
international enfin qui est françois
hollande
à part la risée de l'univers à peine
était-il élus qu'il a accepté que les
nord-américains installe des bases de
missiles antimissiles soi disant pour
parer les missiles que l'iran était
censé vouloir de nous tirer dessus
voici qu'entre temps il se réconcilie
avec l'iran mais que les bases de
missiles s'y trouvent et par conséquent
la russie est menacée vous voyez bien
que nous sommes en train d'aller
progressivement à une situation de
guerre alors rouvrons très réussi et je
pourrais dire que l'attitude de françois
hollande participe de l' escalade qui
conduit à la confrontation avec la
russie quant à lui françois hollande ne
cesse de dire des choses qui n'ont pas
de sens en temps poutine était un ennemi
puis un jour il reprend mon vocabulaire
et il dit la russie n'est pas un ennemi
mais un partenaire le surlendemain il a
encore changé d'attitude et de
vocabulaire
tout ça rend la france il
cible inefficace et absent dans des
conditions de règlement du conflit en
syrie on ira ray vous l'avais dit il ya
un instant vous contestez par ailleurs
la volonté de la france d'engager une
action devant la cour pénale
internationale pour les crimes de guerre
commis par la russie avec avec ses
avions qui bombardent aujourd'hui encore
à alep faisant de nombreuses victimes
civiles est ce que vous contestez la
notion de crimes de guerre imputés à mes
jeux à la russie tout ça ce sont des
bavardages
il y à une guerre c'est une réalité
terriblement dur nous sommes d'accord ok
jean michel grossiord alors nous allons
commencer par dire que nous n'aimons pas
les bombardements ni vous ni moi
d'ailleurs nous ne les avons jamais aimé
ni quand on détruisait lorient brest le
havre caen pour essayer de tuer la
poignée de nazis qui se trouvait là donc
n'avons jamais mêlé baude et la guerre
dans votre livre vous dites la guerre
est toujours salle el al est aujourd'hui
plus que jamais ni plus ni moins l ess à
l'aller horrible à les abominables les
bombardements des saoudiens au yémen
sont abominables
les bombardements sur les civils quels
qu'ils soient sont abominablement mais
monsieur gossio les bombardements vous
voulez voir de ma bouche sortir le mot
russe pour que ça rentre dans le
vocabulaire ambiant alors les
bombardements en général sont
condamnables monsieur jean michel
grossiord arrêté avec la politique de
disneyland
il y à une guerre et les deux parties
essayent de la gagner je verrais bien la
tête et les questions que vous poserez à
vos invités
d'ici quelques jours quand commenceront
les bombardements sur mossoul
vous les trouverez divin parce que
libérateur vous savez qu'il ya des
français qui sont engagés là bas vous
savez que l'artillerie c'est les
français qui l'organisent
et à ce moment là qu'est ce qu'on dira
évidemment on fera pas de reproche à nos
soldats qui obéissent et qui ne le
regarde on se demandera quelle île sans
de me saoulé le siège du groupe etat
islamique on parle aujourd'hui de
bombardements qui affectent la
population civile particulièrement
d'accord à ce créneau suyapa de civils
bien sûr bien alors à l'aide de quoi
parlons nous à l'est dit le dites le
nous parlons de la zone s d'alep qui est
tenu par qui part qui jean michel
grossiord des modérés des modérés
d'al-qaïda qui ont assassiné
les rédacteurs de charlie hebdo vous
tenez à tout prix à trier entre je vous
pose des questions convenues et 15 ans
mais vous voyez ma cette notion de
rebelles acceptable
rien pour l'occident par l'occe la
guerre
la guerre elle est abominable il faut
l'arrêter et pour cela il faut faire une
coalition universel c'est-à-dire qui
regroupe absolument toutes les parties
prenantes au conflit pour d'abord en
finir avec les forces armées des milices
de l'islamisme politique puisque c'est
ce que nous combattons là bas et
deuxièmement il faut mettre sur la table
les vrais problèmes de cette guerre qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la religion qui
sont les frontières des quatre états
concernés dans la situation des kurdes
et le passage des oléoducs et des
gazoducs
on ne veut pas parler de ça de temps à
autre il y à des ouvertures dans le ciel
et on peut un peu parlé des problèmes de
fond vous n'arrêtez pas une guerre si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord pour traiter
des problèmes qui l'ont déclare donc il
faut en parler il faut accueillir
vladimir poutine ait accepté de le voir
à ces conditions où il faut imposer
comme le fait aujourd'hui françois
hollande mais ça n'a pas de sens
monsieur jean michel grossiord vous
voulez poser des conditions à quelqu'un
avec qui vous voulez discuter vous
voulez discuter avec lui à condition
qu'ils soient d'accord avec vous c'est
ça une discussion je comprends que sur
un plateau ça soit la règle il faut être
d'accord avec le joueur avancer la paix
dans la vie faire avancer la paix ça
nécessite qu'on s'en donne les moyens
et pour ça il faut que la france
elle-même cesse d'être le petit
répétiteur des états unis d'amérique
si nous étions indépendants nous serions
en situation de faire avancer nos idées
nos propositions notamment celle d'un
cessez-le-feu général un cessez le feu
que les nord américains ne violerait pas
cette suite vous dit françois hollande
et le perroquet des états unis mais pas
en case érigé par les deux perroquets
les états unis sont totalement
silencieux vous avez vu dans la phase
actuelle il n'existe pas a pratiquement
avant ça c'est le point de vue de ces
crimes de l'ennemi on met lass est mis
en cause la question vous avez justement
les américains sont quand même un auront
les américains sont présents ils
manipulent leurs pions il bombarde là où
il estime nécessaire de le faire ils
n'ont rien fait pendant des mois tout en
faisant semblant de s'agiter contre
dahesh et maintenant chacun essaye
d'occuper le plus de territoire possible
mais vous verrez bientôt que les russes
vont s'entendre avec les turcs qui
jusque là étaient les alliés des
nord-américains et faisait transiter le
pétrole clandestins de dèche et
maintenant ils vont s'entendre ensemble
pour le tracé du gazoduc ya ce moment là
la guerre va ralentir mais néanmoins
monsieur jean michel grossi en scène ce
jour arrivera
quand ce jour arrivera vous ne me
poserait plus la question de savoir si
j'approuve l'un ou l'autre et vous ferez
comme tous les autres d'où vous tirez
pendant qu'on massacre aura les kurdes
ce qu'on est déjà en train de faire
parce qu'il dérange tout le monde
derrière monsieur michel grossiord les
situations complexes ne peuvent hélas
pas rentrer dans les formats de télé a
très bien on a essayé quand même vous
avez fait valoir votre point de vue sur
que c'était clair entre les gars vous
aviez déclaré en février dernier je
pense que vladimir poutine va régler le
problème en syrie
vous le pensez toujours alors attendez
monsieur michel grossiord vous voyez ça
c'est un procédé de journalisme je peux
répondre oui ou non
alors je réponds mais cette phrase elle
est à l'intérieur d'une émission je
venais on venait de me demander comme
vous rayer ce qu'on fait maintenant
concrètement il y avait des
bombardements que bombarder les russes à
ce moment là non mais je vous pose la
cua dire que vous n'en savez rien et
vous lisez votre papier
il s'agit ont bombardé à l'époque les
convois de pétrole clandestins qui a les
deux scieries en turquie risée et les
russes bombardé ça et c'est dans ce
cadre j'ai dit je pense qu'ils vont
faire le travail et maintenant je vais
vous dire autre chose
je n'ai aucune tendresse pour les
islamistes qui se trouvent dans alep est
ce parce que c'est eux qui ont assassiné
les journalistes français et par
conséquent je ne veux pas entrer dans
cette logique simpliste où il faudrait
approuvé les bombardements d un
désapprouvé ceux des autres non je veux
la paix et je vous redis je vous redis
solennellement il y à un risque de
guerre généralisée en europe en neurones
roms en europe aussi car les bases quand
ça les états unis d'amérique en pologne
et les troupes qu'il déploie sur le
terrain avec l'accord des français sont
une provocation antirusse qui n'ont
aucun intérêt stratégique et sont
nuisibles aux intérêts de la france
si vous voulez vous battre pour la paix
il faut être indépendant voilà ce que
moi je défends dans cette campagne
présidentielle et peu me chaut que les
gens changent d'avis tous les jours moi
je ne change pas d'avis tous les jours
voilà qui est dit sur cette crise
diplomatique
donc on poursuit maintenant avec jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
l'épreuve de vérité
que du classique et les échos bonsoir
alors votre occupation et non aux
questions à jean luc mélenchon alors au
nom du peuple puisque vous êtes vous
voulez le porte parole du peuple qu'est
ce que vous feriez pour que les forces
de l'anp puisse intervenir dans les
zones populaires sans être agressé de
manière parfois extrêmement violente
comme on l'a vu il ya quelques jours à
la grande borne à côté d'eux les riches
at il que vous connaissez bien vous
verrez bien puisque je vais lire et
l'huile exactement et bien sûr alors
d'abord deux choses au nom du peuple est
le slogan de madame le pen donc si vous
voulez bien on utilisera un autre repère
parce que sinon on pourrait créer la
confusion chez ceux qui nous écoutent
premièrement deuxièmement je sais ce qui
est je ne prétends pas représenter le
peuvent vous m'aurez mal compris
j'essaye de le représenter le peuple
existe indépendamment de ce qui porte sa
parole ce qui est nouveau c'est que
maintenant nombre croissant de gens
acceptent de reconnaître qu'il y à un
peuple qui est acteur de l'histoire
auparavant les uns ne reconnaissait que
les prolétaires et les autres leurs amis
point des électeurs maintenant on
commence à comprendre qu'il ya un peuple
c'est à dire un acteur nouveau dans
l'histoire qui s'est manifestée sous
tous les horizons qui auparavant
n'existait pas maintenant parlons des
forces de l'ordre ce que nous avons eues
à viry monsieur doit être nommé par son
nom c'est à dire une tentative de
meurtre c'est une tentative de meurtre
par les images aux yeux de sauvageons
pardon au nom c'est un môme alsace et
l'espoir c'est un mot malheureux ça
c'est l'espoir d'un certain nombre de
gens que l'on puisse une nouvelle fois
montré du doigt une population d'abord
une population et ensuite pourquoi pas
une religion
suivant l'habitude qui est dorénavant
prises dans ce pays non il s'agit d'une
tentative de meurtre par des criminels
qui ont des trafics qu'il faut combattre
jusqu'au bout et qui veulent empêcher
l'installation d'une caméra qui
viendrait les contrarier par conséquent
nous avons affaire à un délit de droit
commun est clairement et fermement
nous devons au contraire bien tout faire
pour montrer qu'il s'agit de criminels
et que c'est pas une attitude de
sauvageons ou je ne sais quoi
d'accord ce ne sont pas des sauvageons
ce sont des trafiquants et des criminels
et qui ont essayé d'assassiner des gens
qui sont en l'occurrence en défense et
par surprise en leur jetant des
cocktails molotov dans la voiture il est
clair que deux
une telle attitude doit être réprimé il
n'y a pas d'autres mots à utiliser que
réprimées alors après faut raison garder
raison garder c'est faire attention à ne
pas leur permettre de se cacher derrière
une autre population qui n'en peut mais
qui n'en peut mais pas c'est pas elle
qui a choisi vivent dans des conditions
pareilles
avec de tels gens à proximité des camps
le premier serait dit qu'il n'y a pas de
zone de non droit en france vous êtes
d'accord
bon parce que la zone de non droit c'est
devenu l'argument pour justifier tout et
n'importe quoi il ya des endroits où la
loi n'avance plus où aller tenus à
distance par ce que il ya plus de
policiers il ya plus de bureaux de poste
il ya plus de 2 il ya plus rien et les
gens sont abandonnés et livrés à eux
mêmes et par conséquent comme toujours
dans les sociétés humaines les plus
forts tiennent le terrain et là ce sont
des criminels
est ce qu'il y a quand même en france
est-ce que vous reconnaissez qui a des
territoires abandonnés de la république
où les forces de l'ordre
pourquoi utilisez-vous un mot comme
reconnaissez vous croyez que je n'ai
jamais nié parce que manuel renaudie
j'étais déjà conseiller général dans une
banlieue que vous étiez encore à l'école
de journalistes donc je sais très bien
je sais très bien ce que c'est que tout
ça l'état a abandonné les populations et
maintenant voici qu'il leur jette à la
figure son propre abandon là où l'on a
fermé les postes là on a fermé le
commissariat de police là on a fermé
l'antenne de sanitaires on vient dire
aujourd'hui comment ça se fait en plus
vous osez ne pas être content et
qu'alors feriez et qu'est ce qu'on
ferait pas ce que vous êtes dans la
dénonciation vous utilisez des mots très
forts mais qu'est ce que vous feriez
vous à la place de dieu d'une du
gouvernement la sécurité pour la
sécurité bien sinon vous êtes déjà
d'accord pour dire qu'il ya un problème
évidemment que c'est un problème quand
bon très bien à votre independent
attaques des marchés
alors à votre avis comment peut-on vague
et le problème du crime prenant la chose
rationnellement du crime organisé comme
on le règle tant en pourchassant les
criminels donc il faut pour ça du
personnel c'est l'arrêt pris soin fasse
autre chose que de protéger une caméra à
deux dans une voiture d'accord quand y'a
plus rien dans le quartier ce que
demandent les syndicats de police en
raison et la population demandent une
protection qui est dû à n'importe qui
dans ce pays vous devez pouvoir vous
sentir protégé parole pas par des par la
police de même que vous pouvez vous
sentir protégé par votre école parce que
vous après
et vos enfants sont élevés et soigné
donc monsieur ma réponse est la suivante
que faut-il faire petit à le contraire
de ce que fait hollande est le contraire
de ce que veut faire sarkozy est le
contraire de ce que veut faire juppé
bien sûr tous veulent supprimer des
postes de fonctionnaires
trois cent mille a dit monsieur sarkozy
six cent mille a dit me sens dans la
peau lisse bitton ramadan la police a
lancé ce qu'on entend dans l'éducation
nationale dans l'éducation de ruines al
dans l'éducation résidents dont quatre
au d'instituteur et on april enseignants
dans la police non mais attendez un
instant on reste sur le son mais on ne
reste pas on ira où je veux si vous
voulez bien mais c'est quand même moi
qui réponds oui c'est tant mieux car si
vous voulez qu'on parle de la police
c'est l'actualité du jour oui je vous
suis en train de vous répondre
on ne peut pas faire de police en
policier voilà ce que je vous réponds ça
me semble un bon centre qui sont donnés
un poste donc si vous voulez supprimer
un poste supplémentaire
vous le serez bientôt car nous allons
faire un point sur la sécurité et vous
même vous rendez compte de l'absurdité
de votre question non ah bon je m'en
rendais bien compte que non vous ne
poseriez par manuel valls annonce
aujourd'hui que les véhicules dans ces
quartiers sensibles auront un dispositif
anti caillassage est ce que c'est une
bonne mesure est ce que ça va dans le
bon sens les syndicats policiers disent
que ça va plutôt dans le bon sens que
c'est insuffisant et que ça va dans le
bon sens mais les cultes et franchement
vous croyez que c'est une discussion qui
vaut la peine d'être mené
alors nous sommes d'accord procès anti
caillassage également je fais une
recommandation mettez de l'essence dans
le véhicule
j'ai oublié de dire une chose s'ils ont
des armes si possible des munitions mais
il faut pas les utiliser dans n'importe
quelle circonstance
nous sommes en train d'enfoncer des
portes ouvertes qui permettent de
tourner autour du problème sans jamais
le régler mesdames messieurs l'élection
de 2017 a pour objet la question
suivante qu'est-ce qui gouverna société
le marché est ce que l'état doit être
expulsé de partout c'est vous qui part
j'ai pas vous pardon mais c'est ce
qu'ils ont voulu à tout prix
n'est ce pas que l'état disparaissent de
partout on a dit qu'il était énorme
qu'il était ventripotent on l'a traité
diplodocus de tous les noms et bien
maintenant vous êtes tous en train de
pleurer sur les conséquences des
décisions qui ont été prises il faut que
l'état revienne dans ce pays car la
france est construite autour de son état
et si vous voulez avoir des
fonctionnaires de police qui n'est plus
peur et qui donc ne se comporte pas
comme des gens qui ont peur il faut
qu'ils puissent exercer leur métier dans
des conditions normales
mais ce n'est pas la police qui
maintient l'ordre je vous le redis c'est
la société qui le maintient elle même
parce qu'elle est en ordre
il ya eu pendant plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois pendant tout le printemps
2016 des manifestations contre la loi
travail des mighty des manifestations
violentes pendant lesquels des centaines
de policiers ont été blessés parfois
gravement
est ce que vous mettez pourquoi est-ce
que vous ne dénoncez pas à cette époque
ces mêmes violences contre les policiers
de la même manière que vous le faites
aujourd'hui contre les peuls ou comment
ces deux fabricants à maurice lorsque
premièrement je les fais et à nombreuses
reprises et à de nombreuses reprises
alors peut-être que vous n'écoutez rien
et que vous vous fichez pas marrer mais
deuxièmement je trouve tout à fait
curieux de la part d'un journaliste au
moins d'habitude vous tenez la balance
égale au moins d'habitude vous faites ça
vous pourriez évoqué le nombre des
manifestants qui ont été nuls et qui ont
perdu un oeil
ceux qui ont été envoyés à l'hôpital
ceux qui sont tombés parce que ça a été
très dur
d'une manière générale et moi j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais contre la
violence et j'ai toujours dit je leur
dis devant vous comme ça tout le monde
l'entendra bien je recommence un
policier qui fait un tir tendu ou qui
frappa no matter se déshonore un
manifestant qui jette un caillou pour
fracasser le crâne d'un fonctionnaire de
police se déshonore je suis contre la
violence c'est pas parce que je parle
fort que je suis en violant je suis
contre la violence mais participe à la
violence des propos comme le vôtre parce
qu'ils indiquent ils montrent une partie
de la population contre l'autre
il laisse entendre par vos propos sucré
et mielleux qu' il y aurait une foule
haineuse à l'égard des policiers qui eux
seraient évidemment indemne de tout
reproche dans cette circonstance ils
font leur métier dans des conditions qui
ne peuvent pas conduire à autre chose
que ce que nous avons vécu ce n'est pas
eux qu'on décide le système de la nappe
savez vous ce qui est une menace dans
détenant vous n'avez jamais manifesté
alors je vais m'expliquer que son
ancêtre des gens et dans des salles en
tension extrême entre ce sujet pris sur
un livre oui dans quelques jours dans un
livre de confidences encore un voilà
françois hollande faut être dans la
confidence pour savoir si la confidence
est vrai à des journalistes du monde qui
aurait trop d'immigrés en france qui
note qu'il n'y aurait pas leur place et
que
l'islam est dans une certaine mesure un
vrai problème pour la république
française qu'est ce que vous qu'est ce
que vous pensez il a dit ça que c'était
un point pour la république française un
problème comme je n'étais pas la
confidence je vais pas sa place dans la
république
j'ai rien compris c'est un problème en
tant que religion qui cherche sa place
dans la république française c'est ce
que ces salades on parle plus d'immigrés
on parle d'une religion on parle de la
de l'islam
il ya un lien que je ne sais pas moi
mais qui est fait par le lit par le nom
mais là c'est vous qui le faites ce que
rapporte le journaliste
non mais je comprends pas parce que les
religions dans ce pays et l'immigration
c'est pas la même chose les des immigrés
karine d'europe de l'est les immigrés
qui arrivent de partout ils sont pas
tous de la même religion désolé pour
ceux qui aimeraient peut-être qu'ils le
soient tous de manière à ce qu'on fasse
le lien je ne sais pas je n'étais pas
dans la confidence mais je vais l'a
résumé le président de la république
pense qu'il ya trop d'immigrés bien
qu'ils nous disent combien c'est trop à
partir de combien c'est trop et à ce
moment là nous pourrons poser comme une
base rationnelle ce problème et nous
verrons que c'est stupide
il n'y a ni trop ni pas assez il y a et
avec cela il faut faire et je mets au
défi comme dise comment on peut faire
autrement je recommence on me dit qu'il
y a j'ai entendu jusqu'à 8000
clandestins dans ce pays
d'autres disent 200000 je coupe la poire
en deux à quatre cent mille dites moi
mesdames messieurs comment on fait
comment on fait pour les capturer on
déploie de la police par tout
naturellement plus personne ne rentre on
attrape les gens vous croyez vous pouvez
faire ça et ensuite vous les ramenez ou
dans quel pays ils vous frappent plus
qu'à espérer qu'ils aillent tous au même
endroit
combien ça fait deux trains combien ça
fait deux bateaux ces attitudes sont
grotesques ma position est beaucoup plus
raisonnable faire en sorte que les gens
n'aient pas envie de partir car ils
partent c'est de l'exil forcé
l'immigration c'est de l'exil forcé
personne ne part en pensant qui part en
vacances
d'accord c'est de l'exil forcé et cet
exil forcé il faut l'interrompre en
cessant de créer les conditions qui font
partir les gens et aujourd'hui vous
autres en europe qui jusqu'à présent
avaient regardé de haut
les immigrés de tous ces pays en exil
forcé vous commencez à les regarder
d'une autre tête parce qu'il ya un
million quatre cent mille exilés forcé
parti d'espagne 500 milles
de grèce alors qu'est ce que vous avez à
dire sur le sujet monsieur le président
de la république qui sont de trop dans
les pays où ils arrivent et combien de
jeunes français s'en vont d'eux-mêmes il
faut ensuite combattre les trafics et
une fois que les gens sont là je demande
qu'on m'explique qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre que de se comporter comme
des êtres humains dignes de ceux là donc
les accueillir autrement que dans les
conditions de la jungle à calais qui est
une honte pour notre pays et pour notre
humanité que nous incarnons les trois
autour de cette table alors de trois
hommes d'ailleurs alors on parlait du
peuple c'était la question de jean
francis vous opposer le puck à
l'oligarchie et je le disais tout à
l'heure
nicolas sarkozy reprend ce mode peuple
il n'a que ce mot à la bouche c'était le
cas notamment lors de son meeting au
zénith on en écoute et vous réagissez
vous dites ce que vous en pensez
jean luc mélenchon peuple de france
reprend ton destin en main peuple de
france n'accepte pas la confiscation du
débat
oui je veux rendre la parole au peuple
oui je n'ai pas peur du peuple ce qui
est dangereux c'est de ne pas écouter la
colère sourde qui monte c'est dangereux
c'est d'ignorer l'humiliation de
millions de nos compatriotes alors met
d'accord mais le peuple alors il ya
quelques jours vous utilisiez des termes
qui était assez similaire à ces termes
là vous dénonciez une oligarchie une
caste des parasites des bons des bons à
rien
si le mais c'est le même registre que
elle voit la ceni c'est tout pareil mais
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
elle a même fait la comparaison texte
mais non ça n'a pas d'intérêt et vous
êtes en train de découvrir l'eau chaude
le peuple est une réalité chacun s'en
réclament c'est la tradition
républicaine il est donc normal que
monsieur sarkozy s'en réclament
madame le pen monsieur juppé monsieur
hollande tout le monde se réclame du
peuple étant cette condamnation de
l'hélico 1,14 il est une fois nous
déposerons d'abord ça sinon on ne se
comprend pas on n'est pas en guerre
civile dans ce pays non sauf erreur donc
on peut parfaitement comprendre que des
gens se réfèrent aux mêmes réalités
après regardez monsieur sarkozy j'ai le
droit de dire à ce moment là il dit au
fond il dit c'est moi qui vous
représente mais comment le peuple
pourrait-il croire un homme qui dit vous
êtes on vous a consisté votre parole
mais c'est lui qui a confisqué la parole
du peuple français exprimée en 2005 avec
la plus grande clarté qui avaient voté
non au référendum et c'est lui qui a été
dire à madame merkel nous signons quand
même après avoir présenté un texte au
parlement que monsieur hollande a fait
approuver en même temps que lui
par conséquent les gens qui ont
confisqué la parole populaire sont les
moins bien placés me semble-t-il pour
venir ensuite sans réclamer voilà le
débat le débat il n'est pas sûr le mot
peuple
il est sûr qui a représenté le peuple
avec honnêteté et avec constant donc il
ment une nouvelle fois voilà ce qu'il
faut dire de cette situation de la
question à dernier s'était dit aussi que
notre système fiscal en france actuelle
était à peu près du même ans que ce
qu'il était sous l'ancien régime qu'est
ce que vous voulez dire par là jeu est
bien une réplique à ben oui ça va c'est
pas un peu quoi une exagération dans
votre wii c'est trop modérée en ce sens
j'exagère parce que si vous trouvez pas
exagérer que les entreprises du cac 40
payent 8 % d'impôts tandis que les
petites et moyennes entreprises en page
c'est que vous et moi nous ne parlons
pas des mêmes réalités en france il y a
un problème
la classe moyenne pour tous sur son dos
par conséquent tout le monde doit payer
et on m'a dit alors monsieur mélenchon
vous allez faire payer la moitié des
français qui ne payent pas d'impôts
indique marc et les autres vont devoir
payer de manière à ce que je parle des
autres c'est à dire cette poignée de
gens qui ne payent pas leurs impôts
voire même à qui ordonne
l'argent sous prétexte de boucliers
filet 15 % de français les plus riches
de france payent 70 % de l'impôt sur le
revenu eh bien ils ont tant vous
attendent de paroles extrêmement gênée
ce n'est pas la même
vous savez c'est un phénomène il est
rapporté c'est une manne apportée en
mais non mais non mais non mais vous
pouvez me dire mais non si c'est laisser
la règle pour cent non monsieur ce n'est
pas la réalité
une présentation qui ne correspond pas
aux faits ce n'est pas 10 % de français
qui payent 70 pour l épiscopat 60 % de
l'impôt sur le revenu sur le revenu
absolument bien
et bien cette situation mérite d'être
regardée dans le détail quand je vous
dis que ce n'est pas vrai qu'ils payent
70 % des impôts qui sont perçues par
l'état nous en sommes très bas pour cent
des foyers les plus riches de france
paye 20 % d'impôt parfait et dans ces
conditions grâce à vous nous apprenons
que les entreprises payent tellement que
un certain laurent de l'argent comme
madame bettencourt qui paye zéro impôt
sur la fortune vous trouvez pas ça
choquant ça vous paraît pas choquant ça
ne vous paraît pas choquant que les très
grandes fortunes de notre pays ne
participent pas à l'effort national ça
vous paraît pas choquant est ce que de
très grandes entreprises de ce pays ne
payent aucun impôt s non ça ne vous
paraît pas choquant elle y contribue
considérablement parce qu'elle paye un
très lourd impôt sur le capital et sur
les relais des spectateurs apprécieront
qui représente quoi vous et moi
représente pas les mêmes c'est là les
gens francis représente une radio et un
journal il vous pose des questions et
vous vous représentez a bien failli me
poser des questions aux fichiers nord
plus idéologique jean luc mélenchon et
on va dire merci beaucoup à jouer facile
pour la précision de cette question
comme chaque semaine et c'est maintenant
notre consoeur stéphanie le rouge de la
lfp qui vient pour la suite
l'épreuve de vérité avec les filles
donc bon soir stéphane richard alors
votre question à jean luc mélenchon et
bien donc nous allons nous pencher sur
le visage de cette france insoumise donc
vous réunissez
votre convention
ce week end avec notamment six cent
cinquante personnes qui ont été tirés au
sort est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce choix qui est assez merci
de commencer par là c'est à dire le
mouvement lui même je sais que c'est un
objet nouveau
c'est donc un prototype que nous allons
voir ce dimanche il y aura donc des
choses imparfaite je le dis parce que je
suis un peu angoissé savoir si nous
allons réussir tout ce que nous
entreprenons
nous avons tiré au sort les deux tiers
de la convention si je me trompe pas 650
sur le millier qui va y avoir parmi les
signataires il y en a cent trente cinq
mille de la france insoumis c'est à dire
des personnes qui ont décidé de donner
leur appui à ma candidature
pourquoi vous me tirer au sort pas parce
que c'est plus démocratique de tirer au
sort c'est un débat qui est très ouvert
mais parce que nous ne voulions pas
d'élection car élections voudrait dire
que nous deviendrions un parti avec des
plateformes des tendances des textes
d'orientation et des gens se présentant
à cette convention au nom d'une chose ou
au nom d'une autre en réalité la
convention son objet est réglé puisque
le programme
amy a été mis en discussion a été
élaboré pendant sept mois par des
contributions individuelles sur la base
du programme l'humain d'abord que
j'avais déposé il y a eu des auditions
il y en a eu 16 ou 17 e hier soir j'ai
encore participer à la 18e sur les
logiciels libres
bref et ensuite les organisations
politiques qui apportent leur soutien à
ma candidature en elle-même t leur
proposition de tout ça nous avons tiré
un texte qui lui même est en ce moment
en cours de vote à l'intérieur des cent
trente sept mille votants il a fallu
tirer au sort et nous allons donc faire
quelque chose que personne n'a jamais
fait tirer au sort une convention des
gens viennent ils participent à un débat
dont il est l'objet d'actes de cette
convention parce qu'on comprend pas bien
donc le diagnostic pour vous il est
derrière vous le programme
le mans s'est fait également qu'est ce
que tu vas faire là d'abord nous allons
dans les vous m'interrogez sur les
choses que nous allons factuellement
enfer d'abord nous allons comment dire
transmettre le document c'est un acte
que je ne pouvais pas faire de moi même
j'ai pensé qu'il fallait le faire du
mouvement la présentation du programme
au fait oui nous allons le présenter
il aura encore des modifications
j'imagine de dernière minute il y aura
un classement des priorités qui va être
fait par les participants et il y aura
quelque chose qui me paraît très
important très important c'est le
donnait à voir
nous avons commencé à le faire avec le
défilé de la france insoumise le 5 juin
dernier à stalingrad
c'est le moment où l'on donne à la
parole à ceux qui ne l'ont jamais par
exemple des syndicalistes par exemple
des lanceurs d'alert par exemple des
gens qui dans la vie quotidienne
incarnent des choses dont vous n'avez
pas idée moi non plus parce que je ne le
vis pas mais qui sont les problèmes de
la vie de tous les jours vous avez
quelqu'un par exemple qui a prévu de
venir et d'intervenir savez vous de quoi
elle va parler je ne dis pas que ce soit
un résultat pour l'instant ce n'est pas
encore le suspense est à son comble ce à
quoi alors oui je comprends clair mais
c'est quoi
bah laissez moi finir mari était aimable
avec quoi de toutes sortes de choses
vous le verrez bien dimanche
alors voilà pour la composition et
l'organisation en général ce sont des
gens qui honda a posé des problèmes de
la vie ordinaire sur la table qui ne
sont pas connus pas entendu puisqu'il ya
neuf millions de personnes dans ce pays
qui sont dans la pauvreté et qui n'ont
pas la parole
voilà donc on va essayer d'être ça de le
donner à voir de macron avec ces
marcheurs qui sont venus exposer au
cours du test diagnostique qu'il a fait
la semaine dernière à strasbourg
les problèmes d'accès par madame jeudi
et est remonté je n'y étais pas là
peut-être que tout le monde fait comme
moi je n'en suis pas du tout déçu cela
change la mongie hautes herbes
on va essayer je ne sais pas non je ne
réclame rien c'est vous qui m'avez
comparé à monsieur macron avec qui je
n'ai rien à voire politiquement et avec
qui je n'ai pas les mêmes méthodes mais
vous vous trouvez important de comparer
les deux donc nous allons en tirer une
conclusion c'est qu'il y a un grand
dommage dans la sphère politique qui
aujourd'hui par ses formes
traditionnelles a beaucoup de mal à
représenter l'opinion et la démarche et
les attentes des français en ce qui
concerne
le processus la france un swisscom
mouvement c'est que ce n'est pas un
parti mais que nous bénéficions autant
que nous pouvons de cette merveille
qu'est une plateforme internet qui
permet à chacun d'intervenir comme il
veut quand il veut autant qu'il veut et
moins quand il le veut dans le courant
même de la convention des gens vont
intervenir qui ne seront même pas
présent physiquement dans la salle mais
qui vont le faire parce que en streaming
ils suivent la convention et peuvent
intervenir soit par des tweets soit par
des sms
donc ce sont tous ces objets qui nous
essayons de mettre en place pour avoir
la plus grande implication possible
pourquoi c'est là que je viens au fond
c'est que le projet politique que je
porte est un projet de révolution
citoyenne c'est à dire de prise du
pouvoir par les citoyens qui va se
traduire notamment par une revendication
qui me paraît mois de nature
révolutionnaire c'est la convocation
d'une assemblée constituante pour les
lésions l'art les urnes
oui bien sûr quel autre révolution faire
que celle qui aurait pas religion en
tout cas moi je n'en propose pas
d'autres très bien il y aura un collège
de
représentants politiques aussi ce week
end vous avez des socialistes des
écologistes des communistes qui sont
avec vous oui alors vous savez ils
subiront ce qu' ils ont à subir de tels
cas c'est que comme ce ne sont pas
toujours des personnes très illustre on
considère que ne sont pas là et voilà
pourquoi depuis des mois que nous soyons
135000 on me dit que je suis seul
quoiqu'il y ait des communistes insoumis
des membres d'ensemble c'est à dire des
composantes du front de gauche plus le
pg plus des socialistes dissidents ont
continué à me dire que je suis tout seul
pour être honnête ça ne me dérange pas
car si je bénéficiais des louanges
universel j'aurais aussi tôt le prob
universelle qui accompagne ce qui nous
louanges dans ces circontances tous les
cas officiellement le pcf will you tube
10 novembre
le parti communiste français notamment
bien sûr veux pas l'être ne veut pas et
dit aujourd'hui ne se prononcer que pour
un programme est pas un candidat donc
pas pour vous jean luc mélenchon on
écoute pierre laurent quand même
il mise sur un possible rassemblement
les insoumis avec jean luc mélenchon ont
travaillé les socialistes critiquent
travail je lisais un vrai à la fête de
l'humanité comme mélenchon les écologie
sont en train de discuter et bien
rapprochons nos propositions je pense
qu'elles elles sont elles peuvent être
possiblement commune sur énorme et mon
sujet et faisons une candidature commune
alors est encore possible d'imaginer un
rassemblement seul manifestement de la
fête de l'humanité pierre laurent avait
dit qu'il souhaitait vous rencontrer
pour évoquer un certain nombre de sujets
qui vous divise
il ya notamment la question des
travailleurs détachés de la base de la
france on apprenait l'union européenne
il ya également la question des gauches
irréconciliables donc plus une question
stratégique
vous n'avez pas souhaité cette rencontre
pourquoi déjà et ce qu'elle peut avoir
lieu
non ils continuent d'appeler oui très
bien les communistes participe par
milliers à la france insoumis je le
répète ce n'est pas un parti il n'y a
pas besoin d'abandonner son parti pour
militer à la france insoumise donc des
communistes des élus communistes
parraine ma candidature et il y en aura
d'ici peu davantage encore on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure
mais donc voyons la méthode ce que dit
pierre laurent est toujours très
intéressant et je n'écoute avec toujours
beaucoup d'intérêt par exemple il a
décidé que tous les communistes
candidats aux législatives seraient
investis en septembre il l'a fait il a
dit qu'il ne veut pas d'accord national
qu'il qualifie de tripatouillage met
d'accord au cas par cas et bien parfait
nous ferons des accords au cas par cas
la france insoumise aura des candidats
partout
je répète la france insoumise aura des
candidats aux législatives dans les 577
circonscriptions des candidatures mais
c'est où
nous verrons cela donnera des candidats
oui oui va très bien il y aura des
candidats communistes france insoumise
c'est ce que je peux dire
quant au reste je n'en sais rien car ce
que dit pierre laurent est intéressant
mais je voudrais montrer si vous le
permettez un instant la limite de qui
parle-t-il
les socialistes sont engagés dans une
primaire at il entendu dire que l'un
quelconque des candidats à cette
primaire a l'intention de venir faire
une candidature commune hors du ps avec
nous non at il entendu un seul candidat
vert à la primaire dire qu'il veut faire
une candidature commune non quand est ce
que j'ai essayé tout ça pendant les
départementales et les régionales j'ai
proposé que nous appelions l'opposition
de gauche que nous ayons d'un label
comment tout ça a été refusé
et maintenant sept mois avant l'élection
on serait là a commencé je ne sais
quelle obscure de trop tard mais pas
c'est pas moi qui le dit mais c'est la
conclusion que en tirer la conclusion
que j'en tire et que je suis candidat
disponible à tout moment à parler avec
ceux qui veulent parler avec moi mais
que l'effet m'ayant donné raison je
demande qu'on considère que ce que je
fais aussi un intérêt et votre
candidature et de jeunes irrévocable
évidemment ma candidature
ça va de soi et vous ne payez pas une
plate forme législative par exemple qui
réunirait les communistes et écologistes
vous même
nous verrons la plateforme les
législatives c'est l'année prochaine
nous sommes pour moi l'élection
présidentielle élections législatives
c'est la même chose c'est la même chose
c'est à dire que c'est au nom du même
programme
c'est au nom du même objectif de
victoire moi je suis pas en train de
faire du témoignage je trouve très
sympathique tout ce que dit pierre
laurent mais vous auriez dû vous donner
le mal de regarder en quoi consiste le
programme dont il parle cet axe qui sont
à un niveau de généralité
on ne gouverne pas avec ça bon par la
force des choses pour un programme
sérieux il faut qu'ils soient chiffrées
il faut qu'il soit organisé
on peut pas dire allez venus tous mettez
vos légumes dans le potager on va faire
une soupe mais non un programme ça une
cohérence quand moi je vous parle de la
constituante
eh bien il se trouve qu'une partie de ce
qu'a évoqué pierre laurent n'en veulent
pas quand je parle de la planification
écologique ou de la sortie du nucléaire
ça commence par le parti de la direction
du parti communiste lui même qui n'en
veut pas alors nous ne pouvons pas dire
venez tous et puis on va finir par
arranger un petit quelque chose
non il y a il faut construire une
majorité populaire sur des objectifs et
avec une candidature c'est ce que
j'essaye de valeur votre message
maintenant il va être show charlie
monsieur gros sûr mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez qu'ils changent nous verrons
bien mais rien ne changera rien ne
changera et en tout cas ma détermination
elle ne changera pas il pourra la
retrouver ça c'est clair
amis partenaires et son plaisir à mes
amis tous les jours vous aimez bien mais
on avait un accord stratégique il a cru
qu'il pouvait faire une primaire avec
l'aura compris et maintenant ils s'en
débrouille on a compris il s'en
débrouille merci beaucoup
stéphanie est maintenant c'est mickaël
szames s2 public sénat car ils font la
troisième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
avec jean luc mélenchon
bonsoir alors la question elle va être
posée par quelqu'un qui vous n'aviez pas
envie de répondre tout à l'heure mais on
va quand même l'écouter c'est jean marie
le guen sur vos intentions réelles en
écoute non seulement mélenchon a été
depuis de façon régulière contre
essentiellement qu'on en parle de la
social-démocratie et le parti socialiste
mais ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est aussi des évolutions moi je me
demande si on ne prépare pas à vote
révolutionnaire de se connaître à vous
suggérer que jean luc mélenchon de faire
battre françois hollande de sa cohésion
ça peut aller plus loin bon vous êtes
arrivé à aller plus loin de faire et ça
peut aller plus loin la théorie du chaos
il la portait et je veux dire pose la
question de savoir s'il n'est pas un des
tenants de la théorie du chaos
trop drôle quoi la théorie du chaos dit
le dr le guen il paraît qu'il est
docteur la théorie du chaos il porte la
théorie de la théorie du chaos c'est une
théorie de mathématiques ça rien à voir
avec moi j'ai écrit un livre en 1990 qui
s'appelait à la conquête du chaos dans
lequel j'ai essayé de transposer ce que
j'avais croyez avoir compris de la
théorie du chaos dans le matérialisme
historique doute c'est grotesque
ils essayent de vous dire mes hanches ou
et pour le chaos mais a joué pour le
chaos de 8
venez vite vous réfugier auprès de le
guen alors après il ya un point sur
lequel il a raison en est le
gestionnaire
pardon vote révolutionnaire non je ne
comprends même pas ce que ça veut dire
cher monsieur ben en 1981 par exemple
les communistes avaient appelé à voter
contre françois mitterrand avant au
premier tour ah bon et oui ça oui
forcément
oui bien sûr il y avait un candidat donc
il a appelé à voter pour le zapper ça le
vote révolutionnaire
ah bon vous croyez que c'est ça vous
appelez ça comment vous eu quand on est
communistes qu'on appelle à voter pour
son propre candidat c'était les
consignes secrètes souvenez nous seuls
ou en chine secrète c'est parce qu
restée publiquement on parle plutôt
effectivement de quoi une perspective de
voter pour faire barrage au candidat de
la gauche
c'est ça le chaos je comprends alors
soyons sérieux que des communistes
appellent à voter pour leurs propres
candidats me paraît être normal donc
c'est pas le sujet
d'ailleurs moi je ne suis pas communiste
je ne suis donc pas concerné par cette
affaire
maintenant il dit jean luc mélenchon a
toujours été contre la social-démocratie
banon n'ait pas toujours été contre la
social démocratie
j'ai été contre la social démocratie à
partir du moment où elle est devenue
cette organisation internationale qui
dans la moitié des gouvernements
d'europe cogéré avec la droite et c'est
le cas notamment en allemagne
n'est ce pas et en france elle se charge
elle-même de tout le travail
mais commençons on parle de la
social-démocratie ya jamais eu de social
démocratie en france
n'est ce pas la défense en hollande
c'est pas de la social démocratie non
c'est du libéralisme matinée de discours
de gauche mais c'est ce n'est pas ça n'a
rien à voir et la social démocratie
je vais vous expliquer ce qu'est la
social démocratie c'est un accord entre
le parti de gauche dominants et les
syndicats d'ouvriers pour négocier avec
le patronat des avantages pour les
travailleurs savent passe comme ça c'est
là que c'était la tradition de toute
l'europe du nord jusqu'à ce que la
social-démocratie de toute l'europe du
nord se mettent à gouverner avec la
droite et on définitive avec le patronat
bien donc en france expliqué de m'avoir
ce qui est social démocrate dans la loi
elle comme riz non s'est excusé lors du
patronat non mais je vous dis je vous
résume donc je suis contre cette
orientation là de même il dit est contre
le ps
en effet depuis le début du quinquennat
deux messieurs françois hollande
j'explique ce qui va se passer et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé j'avais
expliqué que la politique de l'offre ne
conduiraient à rien car à une gabegie
d'argent public en pour permettre à des
gens soi disant d'investir ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait ils n'ont pas investi
l'argent qu'ils ont ramassé grâce au cic
donc pour l'instant je ne suis coupable
que d'une chose avoir eu raison
alors à partir de là monsieur le guen
qui ne sait plus quoi dire qu'ils ne
sait qui ne s'est même pas donné la
peine de lire mes textes mes programmes
et autres m'accuse je ne sais quoi de je
ne sais quoi il y dit oui soyez prêt à
favoriser le vote de nicolas sarkozy en
gros faire exploser le système mais je
suis candidat moi même comme henri
favoriser le vote pour monsieur nicolas
sarkozy je ne comprends rien ce que vous
me dites que je suis candidat j'appelle
à voter pour moi on avait comme vous
aura pas échappé
en tout cas pour un deuxième tour
éventuellement de faire de favoriser
l'élection d'un candidat de la droite
pour faire maths la gauche il a un
deuxième tour vous aurez un camp je ne
comprends rien ce que vous me dites y
aura un candidat de gauche et un
candidat de droite
c'est possible et c'est pourquoi c'est
par mois
de gauche je ne sais pas peut-être
bâtisse est peut-être pas voter c'est la
théorie générale on reste là dessus donc
vu que vous répondiez ou pas j'essaye de
comprendre votre question monsieur
monsieur le guen c'est vous qui vous
êtes fourré dans ce mauvais pas vous
avez un type vous avez un type qui
estime qu' massue gratuitement avec
n'importe quoi et vous vous prenez votre
stylo vous avez raison c'est un ministre
alors paroles d'amis ni ça compte
halle aux grains dit n'importe quoi et
maintenant c'est vous qui devez vous
débrouiller avec un machin pareil pour
essayer de me coincer s'agresser retour
est un peu complexe moment on vous pose
la question oui on lui avait répondu et
j'espère plus répondu si quelqu'un a
compris la question il aura compris la
réponse alors françois hollande
toujours dans ce livre dont on a déjà
parlé tout à l'heure a dit je vais
revenir en force à mahler intérêts de
bain et paréo et autres cas aussi dans
ce que n'avait rien d'autre à faire cet
homme que de discuter pendant des jours
et des heures avec des journalistes
ça je ne sais pas il nous dit que si
jamais en cas de 2e tour il avait un
choix à faire entre nicolas sarkozy et
marine le pen il appellerait à voter
nicolas sarkozy
feriez-vous la même chose écoutez
ci-haut deuxième tour il y avait à
choisir entre le père noël et péter
repent je crois que je voterai pour le
père noël
ça vous va non mais je veux dire tout le
monde y va de son petit pronostic ah bon
parce qu'ils imaginent alors maintenant
il suffit pas draguer les problèmes
réels vous rendez compte dans quoi on
est là on est dans la politique fiction
en permanence ça vous donne des sorties
auront quand même nom mais ce sont des
choses et quand on parle plus du réel on
parle plus des confrontations réel on
parle des suppositions des uns et des
autres qui sont des manipulations
ça vous donne des grandes enquêtes pour
dire il ya des gens de gauche qui
veulent voter au premier tour de la
primaire de droite pour aider monsieur
juppé qui est aussi à droite que
monsieur sarkozy et qui lui a été
condamné parce que monsieur sarkozy est
à droite et qu'il pourrait être condamné
tout ça dégouline de cynisme de manque
d'honnêteté de tricherie partout tout le
temps à tout endroit
vous comprenez pourquoi des gens comme
moi se sentent tellement à l'aise dans
leurs baskets
moi c'est ça j'ai un programme tiers des
amis et on se bat pour convaincre une
majorité c'est la seule chose honnête
qu'on peut faire dans une démocratie
question ces gens sont en train de
transformer en grand moment de la
démocratie française en un pmu grotesque
monsieur mélenchon questions qui
pourraient également se poser table de
gauche et là c'est quand même du fonds
vous êtes vraiment irréconciliable avec
la gauche la gauche chivu verne
qu'est ce que voulez je vous dise
irréconciliables d'abord je suis de
gauche mais s'il vous plaît faites
attention à ce que vous dites parce que
la gauche les gens comprennent que je
suis avec hollande
donc c'est pour ça que je parle
d'opposition entre donc il n'est pas
d'un mouvement bien sûr que non qu'il
n'est pas de gauche il suffit pas de
dire je suis de gauche
il faut encore le prouver enfin écouté
jusqu'à présent le parti socialiste ça
reste la gauche mais écoutez en quoi
tous ces gens là font tilt une politique
de gauche je vous supplie de nous le
dire non quand on a fait la loi elle
conneries comme ils ont le comme ils
l'ont fait quand on s'aligne sur les
états unis d'amérique
quand on laisse un pays avec 9 millions
de pauvres et un nombre de millionnaires
comme il n'y en a jamais eu
quand on a le record d'europe de
distribution des dividendes par les
grandes entreprises ne peux pas dire si
une politique de gaulle enfin écoutez
quand les gens se voient rogner leurs
droits sociaux vous pouvez pas appeler
ça une politique de gauche
donc est-ce que nous sommes
irréconciliables je suis réconciliables
avec ceux qui pratiquent cette politique
et tous les autres sont bienvenu
bienvenus et d'ailleurs on fera de la
politique je pense ensemble mais pas
seulement eux
pardon de vous dire ça souvent vous
sous-estimez cet aspect il ya plein de
gens de droite aussi qu'ils sont
complètement paumé vous avez plein de
petits artisans commerçants petites
entreprises ou moyennes qui se disent
qu'ils trouvent plus intéressant ce que
je raconte que les folies ultralibérale
de monsieur juppé de monsieur sarkozy ou
de monsieur hollande et vous serez
surpris par les innombrables glissement
qui vont se produire de gens qui peuvent
former une majorité pour construire ce
pays sur d'autres bases alors on va vous
suivre dans la suite de votre
candidature rien embarque bien sûr et
vous reviendrez nous voir parler du
choix de la soumission c'est ce livre un
entretien sorti récemment au seuil merci
beaucoup mégane merci jean luc mélenchon
merci à tous bon soir à la semaine
prochaine
bon un poil
m